mit karl marx und den problemen unserer
zeit vor allem aber mit möglichen
lösungen beschäftigen wir uns auch in
der heutigen sternstunde religion zu der
ich sie zu hause herzlich willkommen
heißen
mein gast ist der sozialethiker und
theologe hans ruhe herzlich willkommen
hansa sie haben vor wenigen tagen ihren
85 geburtstag gefeiert
wie geht es ihnen es geht mir
ausgezeichnet es war ein wunderbares
fest mit familie und mit freunden und
dazu haben wir beherzt noch bescheinigt
alters entsprechend guter
allgemeinzustand also mehr kann man
nicht verlangen
das freut uns sehr sie haben ein
reichhaltiges leben gelebt wir haben
sich für die viele dinge eingesetzt
sie waren in einer zeit als gerade der
mauerbau in ost-berlin wasser kurz
danach haben sie zwei jahre lang in ost
berlin gelebt als ende der 80er jahre
der kommunismus seinen niedergang erfuhr
und die sowjetunion zusammenbrach
dachten wir eigentlich alle marx hätte
sich erledigt haben sie das auch gedacht
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt weil max
hat er selber gesagt er sei nicht max
ist also er hatte ganz andere
vorstellungen und ich meine eines der
ganz großen begriffe war die freiheit
bei dass er erstaunlich also kann man
und und ich denke seine analyse der
geschichte der abläufe sagen wir mal die
de buchen seite wochen fatalismus
kapitalismus und nachher neben zeitalter
des politikers also diese analyse
scheint mir zutreffender zu sein je
länger desto mehr und zum beispiel auch
er war eigentlich der erste wer so
richtig die globalisierung beschrieben
hat sie habe vor der sendung erzählt sie
sind gerade dabei oder haben es gerade
beendet nämlich delektieren das manifest
der kommunistischen partei haben sie da
noch mal neue erkenntnisse daraus
gewonnen also zunächst habe ich mal
gesehen
seine dissertation also so ein wirklich
eine waschechte philosophische die
dissertation über als griechische
philosophen und das wusste ich so nicht
und dann habe ich natürlich wirklich
freude am eingang also es geht ein
gespenst um in europa doppelpunkt der
kommunismus das muss man zuerst einmal
so ausdrücken lassen daran freude das
machen wir also ich finde das
inszenieren
die inszenierung will ich großartig also
es gab ja dann später einige kopien da
hat zum beispiel der mutter der religiös
soziale erfahrung er hat mal gesagt
blitze aus der ewigkeit doppelpunkt der
sozialismus
also was ich für den beginn einer eines
buches fand ich das großartig
inszenierung
ich fand dann vor allem also was mir
wieder neu war ich würde sagen eine
präzise beschreibung dessen was in der
globalisierung auf uns zu kommt also
diese erweiterung der märkte und immer
neue märkte
also ich denke die es gibt keine bessere
beschaffen muss immerhin sagen also vor
200 pfalz gehört ja genau wie wir jetzt
auf feiern in anführungszeichen denken
dem zehnjährigen geburtstag von cham
leben also das ganze analytisch hervor
sie geben ihm also recht was seine
gesellschaftsanalyse was die entwicklung
der gesellschaft anbelangt geben sie ihm
auch recht in seiner kritik an der
religion er hat ja auch sehr gerne
gesetze in diesem manifest geschrieben
bei denen er die pfanne oder die kirche
massiv kritisiert dieser bekommt das
bekannte zitat opium religion ist opium
für das volk seine vorstellung ist
wirklich dass religion sozusagen die
leute in eine passive situation versetzt
wie halten sie die kritik also ich habe
hat eigentlich gesagt opium des volkes
aber ich meine schon im eingang beim
kommunistischen manifest kommt nach
diesem wunderbaren
eröffnungssatz kommen dann die
angeklagten sei es der papst und der
zahl und die kapitalisten die sind also
der papst gehört halt und die religion
gehören für ihn in das zeitalter des
realismus 10 tragende säule förderwesen
hin zu werden hatte was dann abgelehnt
denken sie wenn wir jetzt spekulieren
denken sie karl marx würde seiner kritik
an der religion mit blick auf heute
aufrechterhalten ich denke nein weil ich
habe er müsste etwas gemerkt haben ist
einmal sage von parallelen zielsetzungen
also wenn wir ich sage die
mitmenschlichkeit oder auch die
menschenrechte oder die diakonie
tägliche also sorge für die unteren
schichten für die haben also ich denke
hätte im unterschied zu vielen jungen
religion jungen sozialisten heute die
das immer noch nicht gemerkt haben dass
sie auf dem falschen dampfer sind wenn
sie gegen kirche und religion wetter
hätte marx wahrscheinlich gesehen dass
da eine allianz möglich ist wie sehen
sie denn heute die rolle der kirchen
vielleicht auch im vergleich zu damals
sie sind auch ein zeitzeuge 68er
bewegung wo sich die kirchen auch ganz
stark für die gerechtigkeitsfragen
eingesetzt haben wie wir nehmen sie das
war damals und heute
also ich denke sind ganz große
unterschiede damals neben 68
damals gab es eigentlich schwer wiegende
gesellschaftliche politische probleme
welche die kirche damals vielleicht eher
als andere
entdeckt hat man welche probleme zum
beispiel verhältnis zu dritten welt oder
zum beispiel friedensforschung oder zum
beispiel oder die frage der energie und
atom
oder die frage der banken und ich sage
immer damals hat die kirche in einer art
frühwarnsystem hat sie probleme auf die
politische agenda gebracht und sie
konnte das aus zwei und weil erstens
weist die gesellschaften die politik
selber nicht gemacht haben und zweitens
weil sie damals natürlich noch eine
stärkere verwurzelung in der im volk
auch immer also es waren auch ganz so
politisch und ökonomisch und
wissenschaftlich bedeutsamen menschen
die sich damals viel stärker für die
kirche engagiert haben also ein
also das kann sich so nicht wiederholen
aus verschiedenen und den erstens hat
die gesellschaft heute die probleme
selber entdeckt oder entdeckt sie selbst
und ich denke also das ist übrigens ein
fortschritt und zweitens ist die kirche
ein bisschen schwach auf der brust heute
für also ich denke sind wir müssten und
ich sehe mich da auch wir müssen zuerst
eine innere basis und stärke wieder
entdecken damit wir dann den hund groß
auf machen können
ich bin prinzipiell schon dafür dass
sich die kirche politisch engagiert aber
sie muss es aus einer starken religiösen
theologischen legitimation heraus tun
und was haben sie eben gesagt sie halte
es für einen fortschritt dass die
menschen nicht mehr die kirchliche
führung zur benennung dieser problem
haben haben sie sind theologe und
ethiker haben sie ihre ethik eigentlich
stärker säkular verstanden oder es ist
eine für sie ganz klar religiöse
ethische diesen verträgen also ich kann
es schwer ist wenn es ist sicher auch
sehr stark welliges verwurzelt
theologisch verwurzelt und ich habe
natürlich in meinem lehrer karl barth
sehr viel
das haben wir mal theologische
fundamente
getankt also wenn ich zum beispiel also
was ich übrigens heute so nicht mehr
sagen kann eine großartige eigentlich
eine verrückte idee von karl barth also
sagt die eigentliche wirklichkeit
das ist die liebe des vaters zum sohn im
heiligen geist und die eigentliche
wirklichkeit ist die versöhnte welt und
mit dies sagen wir mal mit dieser
biologischen pass im hintergrund bin ich
dann kirchlich und politisch tätig und
sagt jetzt will ich diese welt
verwirklichen
die ja angeblich versöhnt ist und
friedlich ist nun gut ist also ebenso ja
aber gerade diese glaubens auffassungen
die die linke heute in der gesellschaft
nicht mehr vorhanden ist es bei mir auch
nicht mehr so steil aber weil das also
so diese vorstellung dass die
eigentliche wirklichkeit das handeln
gottes ist und die eigentliche
wirklichkeit die versöhnte welt ist da
ich sage da habe ich auch beim zu
bekommen
man komme die dämpfer schon während des
theologiestudiums oder später stellt
auseinandersetzung mit der realität
doch die auseinandersetzung mit der
realität und natürlich jetzt in der
letzten zeit noch ganz besonderes also
sagen wir für mich ist das was wir seit
sieben jahren in syrien erleben ist für
mich die wiederholung des erdbebens in
lissabon welches den aufgewärmt den mut
genommen hat
und also ich kann das so nicht mehr
sagen wie ich das soll nun ich habe
nicht mehr die guten vorstellung also
eines so intakten und verständnisses
einer eine andere wirklichkeit die auch
die wirklichkeit sein so ich bin also
ich würde sagen ich bin ein bescheid
wir werden den dialog muss man aber
trotzdem auch fragen was glaubt ihr denn
also wenn ich sage ich denke wir müssen
als kirche und als theologin insgesamt
bescheidener werden und versuchen
unseren glauben neu zu sag mal zu
alphabetisierung und ich denke immer es
gibt ein reich der liebe ein und wir
sind eigentlich ganz kleine figuren in
diesem gewaltigen welt in diesen gewalt
im kosmos und zu diesem kosmos gehört
für mich das göttliche reich der liebe
allerdings und weist jetzt der punkt
allerdings nicht mit einem allmächtigen
gott zu sondern mit einem liebenden und
leidenden und mit leitenden gott und das
schließt sich für sie aus nein das macht
und das lieben dich
es ist natürlich schwer zu also ich bin
ein das zum ersten mal auf diesen
gedanken kommen
ich habe 83 1983 pension als den
deutschen philosophen in new york
besucht und dann ist mir unvergesslich
wir haben dann überhaupt theologie nach
auschwitz gesprochen und er hat er dann
diese these vertreten gott hat sich im
schöpfungsbericht so hat er das gesagt
er hat verzichtet auf seine allmacht
ich würde so nicht sagen ich würde sagen
ich erfahre und gerade wenn ich an jesus
christus denke und dann den leidenden
christus dann würde ich sagen gott ist
liebe und gott ist leiden und gott ist
mitleiden und gottes licht und gott ist
wahrheit
und das zusammen marc stärker sein als
ein altbekannter allmächtige und aber
das sind ich gebe zu das sind viele ich
denke mir schwebt so etwa sowie eine
personalisierte theologie
es gibt ja die personalisierte medizin
wo also aufgrund der ein format bekommt
aufgrund von werken ist zu jedem
menschen ein spezifisches medizinischen
63 gestellt
ich denke wir sollten miteinander
anstelle von formelhaften wiederholungen
von heeren biologischen setzen sollten
wir miteinander und unsere
glaubenserfahrung reden über unsere
persönliche glaubenssatz auch über
unsere wichtigen erfahrungen austauschen
also theorie von unten und
personalisierte theologie und
authentische theologisch also wie soll
das gelingen wenn gleichzeitig der mut
bei vielen menschen gar nicht mehr da
ist über glaubensfragen überhaupt
nachzudenken geschweige denn darüber zu
sprechen ich erlebe immer wieder dass
leute als besonders mutig betrachtet
werden die sich zumindest öffentlich
darüber äußern oder auch in einer gruppe
von verschiedenen menschen
ich glaube wenn dir was ein bisschen
anders machen wenn wir also uns nicht
hinstellen vor irgendjemand sagen und
das glaubensbekenntnis
herunterbeten oder irgendwelche
theologisch formeln präsentieren sondern
wenn wir versuchen mit anderen menschen
darüber zu reden wie erlebst du gott wie
erlebst du wie stehst du zum leben zum
tod
was sind deine religiösen erfahrungen
haben wir schon miteinander gebetet
was sind deine erfahrungen in der
meditation stellen sie in ihrem umfeld
solche fragen auch in ihrem beruflichen
umfeld beruflich also ich habe ja keinen
beruf mehr
aber es ist eben doch weit vernetzt ja
also ich beginne damit ich beginne damit
und habe auch viel gelernt
also ich denke dass zum beispiel mein
lehrer karl barth der hätte keine große
freude jetzt an meinen letzten aussagen
her weil für ihn war das ganze gebäude
noch fehlen stabil und ich denke mir
wir müssten sie haben ja gesagt die
haben nehmen der kirche und so weiter
wir müssen versuchen mit den menschen
über das zu reden was sie selber fühlen
erwarten sie erleiden denken und dann
miteinander und das austausch
erfahrungen aus dem übrigen dieser
theologie immer der austausch über
erfahrung nämlich die erfahrung der
menschen im neuen testament zum beispiel
also ich denke theologie wüste wieder
stärker austausch über diese erfahrungen
die wir miteinander machen müsste sie
werden
ist das jetzt der die forderung oder die
die idee dass hanns ruder ein reiches
leben gelebt hat wo er nicht nur viel
mit anderen menschen gesprochen hat und
vor allem nach lösungen für ganz
handfeste probleme gesucht hat sie haben
ja letztes jahr ihre autobiografie der
sinn eines autobiografischen hits
herausgebracht und sie haben dem buch
den titel gegeben
ich habe mich eingemischt
reicht das einmischen ja gut
politisch oder ethisch durchaus und wenn
sie jetzt ihre fragen ja wie neu ist
diese sind diese theologischen überlegen
und will in welchem zusammenhang stehen
sie mit dann würde ich sagen nein also
es ist vielleicht eine etwas neuere
geschichte und erscheinungen bei mir
also hat vermutlich auch mit dem alter
zu tun und hat vermutlich mit dem
notwendigen sich anfreunden mit der
endlichkeit tun und hat allerdings auch
damit zu tun dass ich denke auf die
kirche wir müssen die kirche von unten
aufbauen und prinz erfahren was sie
jetzt gesagt an der letzten paar minuten
das ist für mich auch relativ neu ich
war
wenn sie so wollen stark eben nicht nur
wert und beschäftigung mit all diesen
einrichtungen und dass eine nach der
anderen und ein auch ein buch nach
diese im moment wieder an einer
tiefendimension wollte noch einen moment
bei ihren vielen engagement aus bleiben
also sie haben vorhin angesprochen die
energiefragen die beispielsweise
umtreiben oder die frage wie demokratie
noch besser gelingen kann
gerade in einer zeit wo sie auch wieder
erodiert dann natürlich die gesamten
ökologischen fragen die armut fragen sie
haben sich auch immer in einer weise
engagiert dass ihre ideen sozusagen eine
politische umsetzung erlangen könnten
sie haben sich beispielsweise auch stark
für das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
engagiert oder für die für die mögliche
einführung einer erbschaftssteuer in der
schweiz
sie sind aber auch gescheitert mit
diesen anliegen und zwar gescheitert
notabene gerade an unseren
demokratischen machtverhältnissen fuchs
sieht ja
nein also ich sehe dass das was sie
gerade ihre letzte einwendung motto also
gescheitert an demokratischen 2 das ist
ja im grunde genommen
also was wir heute erleben dass nämlich
demokratie ist ja auch ein kind der
aufklärung in gewisser weise und
demokratie und rechtsstaat und gewalten
trennungen gerichtsbarkeit und so fort
und ich denke die krise die wir heute
haben ist die krise der erfahrung von
menschen dass sie von all diesen hehren
aufklärerischen dingen zu wenig haben
sind sie uns erklären also zum beispiel
ist in einer demokratie nach wie vor
der unterschied der löhne der
unterschied einkommen der unterschied
der vermögen gewaltig und sie haben es
nicht geschafft das ist jetzt ein
beispiel wir haben es nicht geschafft
eine soziale demokratie zu sein sondern
demokratie ist im grunde genommen also
ich bin natürlich für demokratie den
zweiten verein aber ich stelle fest dass
diese summen der staat derzeit allein
noch nicht
eine soziale basis geschaffen haben das
jetzt genau dass wir sie heute erleben
wir leben heute im denn wir sagen dem
populismus
wir erleben heute die erfahrung von
menschen dass sie sagen was habe ich
eigentlich gehabt von der demokratie was
habe ich eigentlich gehabt vom recht
also sie sprechen auch diejenigen an die
sich dann verabschieden von von den
demokratischen prozessen um war von
wahlen und abstimmungen auch woher also
ich meine populismus dahinter steckt ja
zunächst auch mal die forderung das volk
soll entscheiden allerdings das volk die
mehrheit soll entscheiden jenseits auch
die mehrheit hat immer recht
ähnliche geschichte aber ich denke wir
haben weltweit in den usa in polen oder
ungarn oder wo auch immer wir haben
machen heute die erfahrung dass die
menschen den eindruck haben in diesen
hehren letztlich aufklärerischen
institutionen kommen wir nicht vor
aber warum ist das so also sie
beispielsweise sie haben geschrieben
auch sie waren bereits als gymnasiast
politisch tätig in denen war es üblich
dass man sich engagiert hat weil man
wirklich davon ausgegangen ist man hat
einen nutzen aus diesem engagement in
einer demokratischen gesellschaft was
ist denn was führten zu dieser erfahrung
der menschen heute dass sie keinen
nutzen für das also wenn sie mich
nämlich hatte ja große chancen ich war
der erste der in meinem dorf der in die
sekundarschule durfte und ich durfte in
die kantonsschule ich durfte steht und
durfte sogar mal nachher noch dort
zählen also ich meine
ich hatte für mich war das kein problem
aber da sei es ja eigentlich gerade das
was ich ausdrücken will die in diesen
hehren begriffen und in den sehr idee
der ausgleich in der idee der demokratie
in der idee das recht es fehlt die
soziale dimension
wir haben es nicht geschafft und das hat
er dann mag 7 im 18 50 uhr marx war ja
dann derjenige der nach der aufklärung
also ganz klar gezeigt hat da fehlt
etwas
also und der dann auch aufgezeigt
ich würde das heute so sagen wir haben
eine zeit der gemerkt merken immer mehr
diese grundlegenden begriffe sind
eigentlich elitär
sie sind auch heute noch ein stück weit
zur schlechte den journalismus wir
hatten zum beispiel rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie sind elitäre begriffe und
fiel für viele menschen in der
wahrnehmung dass sie denn eine habe ich
komme nicht vor
und mein leben und ich meine in der
schweiz ist das noch relativ moderat
aber wenn sie sich die saläre
anschaulich lebensverhältnisse als
einmal von amerikanischen arbeiten oder
oder politischen oder griechischen und
dann denke ich ist heute für mich ist
das auf jeden fall zentral das ist sagt
wir wissen dass an zwei punkten müssen
wir nachbessern die aufklärung
nachbessern
der erste punkt ist wir müssen die
objektive ökonomische lage der unteren
schichten verbessern und daneben das
grundeinkommen und zweitens wir müssen
ein klima der anerkennung schaffen
ein klima in dem menschen sich ohne
scham frei bewegen können mit respekt
voreinander
das sind die eigentlich die zwei jahren
legen die ich habe ökonomische
grundversorgung und neue formen der
anerkennung und des respektes was
könnten solche neuen formen seien oder
wie soll die sich diese frauen also mein
lieblings fangen wir mal mit dazu wäre
die einführung eines obligatorischen
sozialdienstes wir hatten ein militär
die wunderbare einrichtung dass leute
allerdings nur männer aber seinen
klassen miteinander als wie ich auch
noch auf dem stroh und heu geschlafen
haben
und das für den zusammenhalt des landes
war das sehr wichtig und mehr schlägt so
etwas werden sollte obligatorisch
sozialwesens für männer und frauen kann
dann auch noch nicht fertig sein als ein
teil und ein dienst indem also auch wie
zunächst mal miteinander die erziehung
nachholen um miteinander sich
vorbereiten auf die arbeit und
miteinander leben miteinander und ich
denke das könnte eine neue der könnte
wieder neu den zusammenhalt der menschen
fördern
wieso die erziehung nachholen wo ginge
verloren also viele viele menschen heute
haben denke ich defizite in der
erziehung und das merken vor allem auch
zum beispiel er meist und die sagen also
kein anstand und wissen mich was ich
gehört habe davon noch nichts gehört
also ich denke will die schule der
nation in gewisser weise schule lernen
auch ein lernen des miteinanders wie man
anständig miteinander umgeht
das alles wäre wirklich in einem solchen
ganz abgesehen wurde dass diese
sozialdienst dann noch das
grundeinkommen finanzieren jetzt fallen
sie aber quasi mit ihrer these dass die
aufklärung gescheitert sei oder
zumindest nachbesserung bedarf wollen
sie eigentlich all jenen in den rücken
die gerade auf politischer ebene ja
gerade die aufklärung als die begründung
anführen die uns in westeuropa und uns
in den usa beispielsweise gegenüber
anderen kulturen als über übergeordnet
oder damals besser eigentlich betrachtet
trotzdem so in meiner sicht ist das halt
nach wie vor ein elitäres projekt also
das und ich meine dann können sie drei
die die leute zitieren und kann das ist
rund und die großen vertreter darauf
bauen dass das sind elitäre ich habe ja
nichts dagegen
ich finde das großartig aber es fehlt
der moment wo einfache menschen erkennen
da komme ich vor
da komme ich vor wir nehmen das sehr
gerne als schlusswort und ich weiß die
werden weiterhin an diesen themen
arbeiten ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei ihnen für dieses gespräch
nächsten donnerstag an auffahrt zeigen
wir ihnen den film die gabe zu heilen
er geht der frage nach ob krankheiten
durch übersinnliche fähigkeiten geheilt
werden können
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einem
gespräch zu karl marx barbara bleisch
gefragt die philosophin rahel jaeggi
bleiben sie dran
[Musik]